hello freak [ __ ] because he's the
first president to just talk [ __ ] like
it's truly a powerful thing like first
when you have a powerful man most
powerful man in the world you're
censored but this is the first
uncensored most powerful man in the
world he's truly exuding his power Yana
don't give a [ __ ] level well you know me
a little bit of a [ __ ] but not enough of
a [ __ ] to change yeah he only gives a
[ __ ] if he gets dinged a little bit but
he didn't up he doesn't pull back he
just he swaps back defensively yeah in a
way that a listener would want to swap
back defensively at work you know but
still can't because they had Trump seen
so less worried about his job and more
like I'm just going to be me and then or
when Chappelle quit the Chappelle show
like a lot of people found freedom in
that that's why he's so mythical oh for
sure yeah yeah yeah good point
like a lot of people make 60 million
dollars but how many people you know
turn down fifty million dollars there's
fewer of those yeah you know just one
just one
yeah and he also didn't do stand-up in
any scheduled performance for you tires
he just would show up places yeah and he
still dug guys like so he just used it
i'ma show up this place yeah and then
they put out an email however he just
shows no fellows about when I was in
Denver oh yeah yeah I showed up yeah I
go to the green room de Janeiro what are
you doing man hey don't worry yeah he
that's his way I guess of just being
free free yeah do what everyone the only
thing that he has scheduled is the Radio
City thing and that's because I guess
it's Radio City you have to schedule
what does he do he's like does a regular
show there he's gonna do he did a few
years ago now he's gonna do like maybe a
week and a half or two weeks of shows
there and he's gonna get on it like
musical guest comic some day like it
that's amazing I have a comics ball
party that's a great idea yeah that's a
great idea
Wow yeah I mean he does represent what
we all consider to be like the highest
standard of a real comic artists
right you know when you get together
with a group of comedians and you look
at like who's like doing it the right
way right I mean there's other ways to
do it that are really like more
commercially successful like Mary Louis
is more commercially successful in terms
of like constantly chasing it down but
Dave is just also as that mythical
quality to it as well like you're
talking about turning down the 50
million there that has a big factor in
how we look at it - that's his biggest
TV credit yeah surfing doesn't hurt and
down yeah and also like walking away
from the greatest sketch show the
world's ever known
right that is still to me in my eyes the
greatest sketch show of all time I had a
lot of fun as [ __ ] on there oh as far as
like hit or miss right it's the best
ever right like
[Applause]
[Music]